à à savannah films spider savarières si
je vais vous dire ce qui s'est passé ne
viennent pas c'est bien parce que je nie
tout téléspectateur jeu le directeur des
programmes vincent pujol qui venu me
voir discrètement avant l'émission qui
m'a dit écoute une helsing et magnifique
est ce qu elle ne referait pas un petit
défilé quand lorsqu'elle a été miss
france elle film c'est à vous de choisir
ce que voulait nous faire un petit
défilé pour la sélection pas aller
jamais ce qui m'a dit il m'a dit c'est
spectaculaire
pujol delphine est ce que tu es partons
mais laissés en effet partie alors on y
va
[Applaudissements]
quel bonheur d'avoir une ex amie qui est
devenue une collègue de travail il 21
aussi jolie delphine wespiser je vous
rappelle qu'il m'a pas envoyé
c'est peu pour la nouvelle année et elle
est passée de très bons amis que
j'apprécie énormément à une collègue de
travail
mais néanmoins on s'entend bien sam
hamad et le film oui merci tranquille
oui ça va les autres ouais ça va les
dépenses et les missions les chéris